Vivek ramaswamy has been surging
recently in the polls after this past
past weekend especially he was at the
same event as Pence then he did a big
Turning Point USA event the next day and
there's one clip going back to the uh
the Friday event
and he's talking to Glenn Beck about
draining the swamp and we've heard the
promise to drain the swamp we've heard
it from Trump we hear from every
Republican
presidential candidate and Trump was not
the first one to promise that what we
found is that no Republican president
has actually done it Trump included
um
well Vivek is making the same promise
but here he's asked how will you do that
and here's his response
I'm coming in with a clear-sided view
Glenn of shutting down most of the
administrative State how realistic is
that very realistic so first of all do
it on strong legal Authority so I'm a
unique combination I don't like to brag
a lot but I'm a CEO but I've also
studied the Constitution deeply and the
Supreme Court right now shares my view
of the Constitution the U.S president
already has statutory Authority the
presidential reorganization Act of 1977
says you could shut down redundant
agencies well when I look at what the
DEA does and what the U.S Marshals do
there's my legal justification for
shutting down the FBI without asking
Congress for permission or forgiveness
jeez yeah there's another justification
stimulating the economy also in that
same statute the 80 billion dollars
spent in the U.S Department of Education
you know what that would stimulate the
economy to give it back to the people
that's my legal justification so I
understand the legal footing by the way
what stopped Trump the Civil Service
protections they said correct well guess
what read the law Civil Service
protections protect against the
individual firings of employee these for
supposedly political reasons they do not
apply to mass layoffs and mass layoffs
are absolutely what I'm bringing to
Washington D.C would you lay it off
reform it or close it down these
institutions many agencies I would just
shut down the agencies there's certain
lists of other agencies where we have 75
percent head count reduction plans and
then there are other agencies which we
move out of Washington DC make people
move many of them will volunteer not to
we save on the severance costs
imagine that he actually now does the
fact that he has a plan for
accomplishing this does that mean that
he'll be able to accomplish it uh not
necessarily you know having a plan is
not the same as as being able to execute
it
but you should be able to explain
exactly how you're going to do it
and this this is what we should whoever
you support in Republican primary
this is what you should this is this is
minimal stuff this is minimal stuff this
is what you should require of whoever
you support
that whatever their alleged goals are
starting with draining the swamp
and you know getting rid of the
administrative State same thing as
draining the swamp means the same
effectively means the same thing
um
but whatever the promise is starting
with that they need to be able to
coherently explain how they'll do it
what is your plan
walk me through the steps
and just saying I'll do it and it'll be
done
that's not enough
anyone can say that you need to be able
to show that you understand how to do it
to begin with
if you don't understand how you're going
to do it then you're not going to be
able to do it are you tired of waiting
ages for your grill to heat up now you
could say goodbye to those tedious
moments of impatiently watching the
charcoal burn and say hello to instant
barbecue Perfection thanks to our new
friends at Grill Blazer Grill Blazers
Grill guns are designed to do everything
from expertly searing your Meats to
lighting charcoal grills wood stoves and
outdoor fireplaces Grill Blazer offers
two types of Grill guns they have the
grill gun basic which is a high power
propane torch designed to Light charcoal
and wood grills and smokers it burns up
to 3 600 Degrees it's 30 inch flame is
for anything you need a big bad torch to
do and then there's the sous vide gun
which has a shorter Bale Barrel perfect
for professional culinated kitchen uses
from gently caramelizing brulee which of
course I caramelize brulee all the time
I know all about that or other sugars
and fruits to rapidly searing steaks
outside on the grill using the grill gun
may result in extreme Grill Envy from
your neighbors and increase demands for
barbecue parties as well get your grill
gun from Grill Blazer today and let the
grilling Adventure begin visit
grillblazer.com Walsh and use promo code
Walsh for 15 off your order that's
grillblazer.com walls promo code walls
for 15 off your order companies are
strong arming their customers to support
abortion canceling customers for the
political views and making a mockery of
women by supporting transgender models
no government agency institution or
company is allowed to just be what it is
and focus on fulfilling the tasks that
it was made to fulfill a beer company
can't just make beer anymore their
primary concern is not with brewing and
distributing beer but with showing their
support of the less political and
cultural agenda that's the way it is now
but Public Square offers a new solution
Public Square is an app and website
where you can get connected to tens of
thousands of businesses from all
different industries that share your
value for Life family and freedom Public
Square also offers discounts to many
high quality businesses on the platform
so you can actually have an incentive to
spend money with companies that don't
hate you imagine that whether you're
looking for new athletic clothing that
knows what a woman is a banking partner
you can count on or simply a new
restaurant in your area that won't
lecture you about your critical views as
you're trying to enjoy a meal head over
to publicsq.com Public Square is free to
join as a consumer or a business owner
you can get started at publicsq.com or
download their app today that's
publicsq.com this is one of the things I
like about uh Vivek ramaswamy uh and
there's there's still a lot you know my
I like a lot of what he says he appears
to be very competent I agree with much
of what he says
if I have one complaint about him it's
just that he's kind of and this is you
know this maybe this is a holding
against him the fact that he's not a
career politician which is unfair but he
did sort of come out of nowhere and so
there are a lot of questions about like
where did this guy come from what was he
doing before this uh what were his views
all these issues say three or four years
ago I mean all these are important
questions
um but as far as what he's saying right
now I I like a lot of it and this is
this is the
this is the main thing that I appreciate
about him is that he can
in in precise detail
explain here here's where the problems
come from
and here's what we can do to fix it
and
too often we let
Republican politicians
get away with making Grand sweeping
promises that sound really good but
without getting into the nitty-gritty
and the specifics and what we found is
that that really does matter this is not
just wonky nerd stuff
that really matters because when you're
in office if you actually win and you're
there
now it's not about Grand sweeping
promises anymore it's not about
platitudes now you're there now it's a
day-to-day thing and you have to be able
to actually execute
and a lot of what you're going to be
doing a lot of it's kind of like boring
behind the scenes it's not flashy
but you gotta you gotta you gotta love
that stuff
and you have to understand it
uh I think vivek's one of the guys that
appears to fit the bill there thanks for
checking out this video if you'd like to
listen to my full podcast on the go you
can check out the Matt Walsh show on
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts